now like many other people I'm a fan of
the videogame uncharted drake's fortune
along with director amy Hennings other
and less known masterpiece legacy of
kain but this is about uncharted so the
diabolical they you know the ones who
destroyed most everything good in the
world of entertainment they've decided
to bring uncharted drake's fortune to
the big screen which i think is
unnecessary because the game is more
epic than most movies anyway i mean it
is as good as it's gonna get and who did
they cast as the main character nathan
drake i mean will marky-mark of course
who wouldn't think that besides pretty
much everybody and why am i talking
about this today because that is the
dumbest thing I've ever heard since Mark
Wahlberg being cast in Max Payne look I
understand the guy can be a pretty good
match if the role fits but I mean let's
face it I've seen the happening now the
character of Nathan Drake was clearly
written for Nathan Fillion no human
being can deny that he absolutely is I'm
not just saying this as a fanboy I mean
check it out yourself they are identical
and I like everyone else was thinking
Nathan Fillion would be perfect but he
might be a little old I mean the guy's
getting a little puffy and then they
cast Marky Mark who is the exact same
age as Nathan Fillion so I mean there
that is so all Nathan Fillion needed to
do was do the Christian Bale you know
just crack yourself out lose a bit of
weight and boom you got the perfect
Nathan Drake but what do I know I don't
get paid to cast people I'm just a guy
with an opinion that opinion happens to
be that casting Marky Mark is a stupid
choice when compared to Nathan Fillion
after hearing this I went on IMDB and I
checked out Mark Wahlberg's filmography
and no rules the guy has ever taken
scream to me Nathan Drake and yeah you
can argue that no rules that Heath
Ledger had before the Dark Knight
screamed the Joker you can tell the guy
was diverse he could play different
roles Wahlberg is one kind of character
all the time and the roles just have to
fit him which Nathan Drake really does
not Mark Wahlberg would have to be
everything that Mark Wahlberg is not in
order to be Nathan Drake and apparently
it gets better trust me they want Robert
DeNiro and Joe Pesci in the movie to
play Nathan Drake's father and uncle do
the thing they're sticking to the story
on this one so to show you guys what we
have to look forward to I have Nathan
Drake's lines from Uncharted delivered
by Mark Wahlberg first we have keep
smilin I'll see you soon hey you
told me not to move right so looks like
you're gonna have to come get it of
course your jump ten to five and blow
the cord so that's it that's my deal die
now we'll help you and then die later
you know that's a tough call but you
know what I'll take that now and here's
my favorite this is when you know
they've butcher
yeah you know what can you go wet yeah I
can't wait I mean if they take this
movie seriously everyone who's played
the games will agree that this could be
the next Indiana Jones instead looks
like it's gonna be tomb raider so what
do you guys think of all this Mark
Wahlberg Nathan Drake I put a couple
videos below so you can see Nathan Drake
and Nathan Fillion and see how you know
I'm right that was a modest moment yeah
but you'll see check them out comment
below let me know what you think if you
haven't played uncharted and you happen
to have a PlayStation 3
you should probably play it but if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more than click right here to see
more
[Music]